hey youtubers it's Charlie because so
much was going on during comic-con I'm
gonna combine my Teen Wolf Episode six
and seven videos right now so this is
mostly gonna focus on episode seven but
I will mention some of the big takeaways
and like the big major WTF things that
we need to talk about from episode six
first I'm also gonna announce who the
winner is of the Comic Con giveaway at
the end of this video too but if you're
just finding me for the first time
either you team will videos every week
be sure to subscribe to get everything
I know we're all really excited we're
gonna get like a full 20 plus episode
season 5 so let's get going careful for
spoilers from episode 6 & 7 if you
haven't seen them yet I'll wait just a
sec okay here we go so biggest WTF stuff
from episode 6 Peter and Kate are gonna
be working together this is not good for
anyone
Kate controls the berserkers but it
seems like neither she or Peter is
connected to the benefactor in a
conscious way previously I thought that
Peter was a good candidate as a way to
get his alpha powers back but now it
seems like he's just one of the other
victims one of the random victims and is
making lemonade with all the lemons
trying to kill him so then there's
Meredith flipping her [ __ ] and killing
herself this probably just the show's
way of getting rid of that character
they were trying to get the last cipher
key but before she killed herself
meredith said he doesn't want me to tell
you and i think this is a really big
deal meaning she has been in
communication with someone whoever he is
and noticed that she said he so it's not
a woman the benefactor is a man the
whole message in a mixed tape thing
feels very weird it feels like a big
effect ation like it's gonna figure
somehow into his character the whole
thing with the record player you know
big analog music source that kind of
figures into that so I'm kind of
wondering what's going on it's like a
very 70s 80s vibe and then there's Derek
being the last cipher key it's almost
like the grim reaper is just gonna like
hang out on his shoulder for the rest of
the season like we're just waiting for
him to die but anyway moving on to
episode 7 I'm gonna do this like I
normally do it just top 5 moments and
then I'll do my review so here we go
number 5 so Tomy is not dead I totally
loved her introduction it was straight
out of a kung-fu fight movie slow-motion
martial arts fight in heavy rain it
actually reminded me of this really
awesome movie called the Grandmaster
it's about it man he was a real-life
person who was one of the greatest
martial artists who ever lived he
actually ended up training Bruce Lee the
whole opening scene of that movie is an
epic battle on the rain so it's on
Netflix and you guys should all watch it
immediately after you're done with this
video
if
like Satomi is just becoming a bigger
part of the story of this season like
she's gonna help Derek and everyone else
fight the benefactor I could definitely
see her sacrificing herself for Scott's
pack her own pack is all dead so unless
she creates a new beta or starts working
with Derek in some way there's not a lot
left for her to do on the show so start
saying your prayers for Satomi because
she could be dead by the finale number 4
big WTF coach used to be a drunk I'm
also using this to talk about the bacne
reveal you know with the virus that's
what I thought whenever she pulled his
shirt off if you were confused about how
the virus worked it would put everyone
down for a little while but non we're
creatures would just automatically get
better after a short period of time so
that's why coach just shot up randomly
and said what the hell's going on
Lydia's mom was so cool during all this
to most the time when we see her she's
being completely ridiculous but we find
out that when things start to slide
downhill she really cares about everyone
especially coach and who knew that he
used to be a crazy drunk 15 years ago
I'm wondering if that has something to
do with him not becoming a professional
athlete alcohol and substance abuse are
big problems for celebrities and
athletes to get their careers torpedoed
remember a coach was actually a pretty
big athlete I guess based on what we
learned during season 3 I don't know if
the show's ever explain explicitly why
he stayed at the school it might be
because of an injury that he suffered I
always loved it when they revealed big
character details like that for minor
characters and how cute was it that
whenever Lydia came in her mother
immediately pretended to be ridiculous
again I think she just did that to make
Lydia feel more comfortable like Lydia
is more comfortable thinking that her
mom is ridiculous and on to number three
another big WTF Stiles wants to keep the
money he got pretty dark whenever they
were talking about it it almost made me
think that he was in on the Deadpool is
somehow just a language that he used and
how passionate he got about not rushing
to give the money over to Peter and
Derek I mean even Scott had a WTF
reaction when Stiles was going crazy
about the money the icon house debt as
well as Scott's mom going bankrupt have
been big ongoing plots this season so
there's two practical outcomes I think
there's the hero option Stiles and Scott
just suck it up give the money over and
look for other overtime work to help pay
off their family's debts heroes do not
steal think of it as like what would
Captain America do Scott is like the
Captain America of the group and Captain
America does not steal money from other
people even if it's Hydra hail Hydra the
other morally ambiguous option is that
they give money to Derek and just keep
Peters
and use that to pay off their debts
because of the trust issues going on
with Molly in the episode I do not see
stiles pushing as hard for this option
if he took the money and Peter found out
it would just be more ammo for him to
drive a wedge between Malia and the pack
Peter is just gonna start drawing more
and more people around him as he gains
more power obviously he's gonna try and
coerce Malia at some point if she
doesn't just immediately rush over to
the law for answers on to number two
creepy PSAT guy is infecting everyone
with the virus if you guys didn't
recognize him he was actually on an
episode of The Office
he played Dwight's creepy friend so
whenever he showed up being creepy on
this show I just laughed a little bit I
feel like his best moment was actually
the first time we saw him whenever he
was in that creepy basement infecting
that werewolf if you weren't sure what
he was doing he was testing the virus to
see how long it took to kill a werewolf
that's why he left the guy on the
hospital bed inside the ring of mountain
ash I thought the whole virus subplot
was a good Oh Maj - cabin fever or
really any infection based movie like 28
days later
I love how Teen Wolf can do John Rose
within genres it's already a show about
werewolves which is a huge genre but
whenever it does other genres it just
gives the story so many other places to
go it seems like a lot of these Deadpool
mercenaries get one Episode arts or
really short ones there's only a few
episodes left so I wonder if the
mercenaries we've run into next will
progressively just get bigger and badder
until we get to that final boss fight
it's like Scott's group is playing Mike
Tyson's punch-out on a classic Nintendo
and they just had to work their way
through the boss stages so that they can
fight Mike Tyson at the end but my
number one WTF moment
Malea learns the truth about Peter I was
pretty surprised by the way she found
out I'd actually expected her in Stiles
relationship to not be a part of that
but we always knew at some point she was
gonna find out and flip and when they
did that whole hiding things moment with
Kiera you pretty much knew it was coming
the big question now is what will she do
after she gets the full story from Peter
and will Peter create some fiction to
keep her close it seems like Scott the
others would have explained Peter at
some point to her mostly that he can't
be trusted and he's a terrible person
that's the logical thing but there have
been some times when Teen Wolf has
played it fast and loose with logic at
Comic Con whenever someone asked Jeff
Davis the creator about Malia learning
to do her hair and makeup and becoming a
real girl he waved his hand and said TV
rules
he was pretty open about saying the
writers just hope that fans would give
them a pass on all the backstory but
they just didn't want to do four
episodes
we're Malia goes through potty training
for the most part I totally don't mind
logic jumps but I hope they don't just
wave their hands too much when it comes
to Peter and Malia she's pissed about
Scott and the others not telling her the
truth but that should not make her
forget what an awful person Peter is but
now it's your turn let me know what was
your biggest WTF from the episode and
what do you think that Mele is gonna do
is she's just gonna run off to Peter or
she's just gonna go off on her own I
feel like the show's teased us way too
much with a Peter Melia moment so I
definitely think we're gonna see that
but in the end I think Melia will betray
Peter to help Stiles in the pack like
whatever ends up happening with the
benefactor Peter has his own side scheme
going off to the side and it's probably
gonna create a situation whereby Malia
is gonna have to choose between helping
him and helping her friends it's pretty
clear that Malia in a situation like
that would do the right thing she's
always gonna ultimately choose Stiles
and Scott Teen Wolf has always been
really good about playing with the
themes of blood being thicker than water
like the fact that Derek is Peters
family but Derek doesn't think of Peter
as family and if Malia doesn't return to
the pack before season five who is gonna
spoon Stiles maybe Derek maybe Derek
will step up they actually do that in an
episode of Family Guy where quagmire is
Peter starts spooning because Lois
doesn't want to do it anymore
overall I gave the episode a solid beat
it had a couple of great left turns with
Satomi and Malia Stiles just got way
more complicated which was amazing Scott
is like the Captain America the group
you know he's always gonna try and do
the right thing
Stiles on the other hand is like the
Bucky he even got brainwashed like Bucky
during three B would it be crazy if
Stiles and Scott had a falling-out over
the money
this season is supposed to be all about
human issues and fighting over money is
a very human thing to do I also love the
way they paired people off in the
episode like putting Derek with Braden
Lydia's mom with the students Malia and
Kira I always tend to favor the light
and funny stories like the LaCrosse
stuff
Malia trying to be human Scott and Kira
relationship humor or like Lydia and
deputy Parrish those are always the best
at least for me so whenever we get more
intense episodes like this one I always
look really hard for the lighter moments
let the Satomi reveal it swung from
crazy Hong Kong fight movies - hey
what's up in a few seconds it's like the
whole episode was a slow-moving heart
attack so when we get those lighter
moments I'm always so happy since we're
halfway through this season I feel like
all of the remaining episodes are gonna
be a slow-moving heart attack but let me
know if you guys agree
do you like the fun episodes more or do
you like
more when things get super intense and
you feel like your hearts gonna burst
inside your chest obviously I'm gonna
cast my vote for the more fun episodes
but congratulations to Karen see you are
the winner of my Comic Con giveaway I'll
be messaging you on your channel for
details
it's basically an Amazon gift card real
quick personal update I just quit my job
to become a full-time youtuber and my
last day is in a couple of weeks I'm
also moving at the end of this month - I
got to move the den so I'm gonna try and
make my video schedule as normal as
possible so Teen Wolf should always post
by Tuesday for the rest of the season
every once in a while crazy stuff always
ends up happening so you can always
follow me on social for updates there's
actually links to that at the bottom of
the description but right now if you
haven't seen it here's a link to the
Teen Wolf Comic Con panel and click here
for my episode 5 video thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives